[Musique]
voilà la dernière fois j'ai voulu faire
une petite vidéo un peu drôle je crois
avoir compris que elle était mal perçue
j'avais fait un peu la folle dans ma vie
et là vous voyez je suis au même endroit
donc tout va bien vous inquiétez pas il
y a pas d'appel à l'aide et tout va bien
pour moi j'ai de très beaux projets je
vais vous surprendre dans le bon sens
donc deux métiers que vous m'avez encore
jamais vu
tu veux qu'on demande aux gens dans la
rue on va demander à quelqu'un vous la
trouvez jolie ou pas non non franchement
tu veux pas qu'on le fasse on va arrêter
quelqu'un alors
vous reconnaissez Jenifer elle me dit
qu'elle est pas jolie
merci Monsieur bonne journée donc là
j'ai pas fait exprès
parce que j'ai du maquillage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]